في عام 1953 ، كشفت جنرال موتورز النقاب عن
سيارة رياضية أمريكية جديدة ، بعد
70 عامًا بالضبط كشفت جنرال موتورز
النقاب عن الخطوة التالية في تطور كورفيت ،
هذه هي كورفيت e-ray ،
أول كورفيت هجين
[موسيقى
] ، أحدث جيل من كورفيت
يمتلك محركها  خلف المقعد ، ترك
مساحة لمحرك كهربائي في المقدمة
، لم تصدر شركة جنرال موتورز أي أرقام اقتصادية في استهلاك الوقود ،
ولكن بصراحة ، فإن استخدام كمية أقل من الغاز
ليس في الحقيقة هو الهدف
معًا لمحرك الغاز الذي يبلغ قوته 495 حصانًا
والمحرك الكهربائي بقوة 160 حصانًا.
655 حصانًا
مع كل هذه القوة والدفع الرباعي ،
أول كورفيت آخر ، والأشعة الإلكترونية هي
أسرع كورفيت تسارعًا على الإطلاق
على عكس بعض السيارات الهجينة عالية الأداء الأخرى ،
فإن كورفيت e-ray ليست
هجينة إضافية مما يعني أن الأشعة الإلكترونية
يمكنها  لن نذهب بعيدًا جدًا في الطاقة الكهربائية
وحدها سوى ثلاثة أو أربعة أميال على الأكثر
بدءًا من ما يزيد قليلاً عن مائة وأربعة
آلاف دولار ، فإن العصر ليس رخيصًا ولكنه
لا يزال أقل بكثير من السيارات الهجينة من
شركات  anies مثل Ferrari و
McLaren كل هذا يتوقف على كيف تنظر إليه